hello and welcome back to this series
where I talk about books I need I
genuinely do need to brown this yeah
what two books total my PhD is nine book
thank you for that input this is mr.
Lewis Bradley hello so Lewis you're one
of the founding members of the aux cast
yes we are here at York studios yes and
so you do well what do you figure the
who don't know who you are what do you
do on the Internet
so I'm a youtuber and twitch streamer I
gave four years now and I appear on
various channels we play various games
so I love I love books and I wish I read
more I mean I think the thing that got
me really into reading and I think this
is weirdly similar for a lot of people
is Harry Potter yeah I enjoyed like but
before then but I think Harry Potter was
a such a good book and you know it was a
good book because it changed my habits
right change my reading habits I was
like staying up later to read it or over
fam I was reading at my desk I was
reading in places I didn't read before
and it really sucked me into that
universe and I was just about the right
age for it when it all came out I was
like fifteen sixteen when they were the
first three were out hmm
and so I followed that you know I was it
was excited about the pre-release you
know it was it was a strange thing to
preorder a book you know and I hadn't
done anything like it before so you know
I like a lot of people I grew up being a
big big fan of Harry Potter and and and
slowly at the time had my joy eroded
away from me okay if that was a step
later in our series the books that came
out I was a little bit older then so
kind of delayed and I didn't really
associate with him that much more and
I'd also read a lot more other stuff in
the meantime I think it kick-started my
reading so I have a big soft spot for it
by ended up reading a lot of things that
I thought were better or have aged
better than the later Harry Potter books
and then obviously the films
I was never a big fan and I think it's
always a tricky thing to have read
and then watching the film adaptation
yeah sometimes I think it can bring it
to life I didn't think that all the
Rings was a very good book when I read
that as a teenager that wasn't something
that sparks interest in reading for me
the order of rings because the famous
thing it was a fantasy that I should
have liked it should have been a gateway
into it but it wasn't and I I read it
and I pushed through it and but the
movies work was fantastic and they was
something that really got me back into
that in a big way and loving the Lord
the Rings universe
was it just too dense was a to comb
tolkien-esque it was it was too heavy
it's a heavy read and I think even now
what rings is a heavy read I think when
you look at Harry Potter it's a very
light read it's very it's very well read
it's very easy
you'll never your eyes never jar as you
roll over it you can skip bits if you
want like and clicks so people some
people like to skim and speed read
through chapters they can't get on with
like sometimes for me I'm one of these
people I used to be a writer I used to
be a science journalist I am someone who
reads every single word I'm not you you
can read these these interesting things
on the internet like where you can learn
like speed reading and you'll flash up
oh yeah fast and we realize how few
words you need to actually read to get a
sentence and speed reading is this thing
where people really smash through these
books and they can really like really
get through a whole load of stuff and
and digest the information but I'm
someone who's I think I've read a
relatively slow pace I read quite and I
don't like to be taken out of there
reading is something that has suck you
in and that you be in your imagination
and you need somewhere kind of so you
don't have to have somewhere quiet but
sometimes like that is the best way to
get you know just
to lose an hour or two in a world it's
not just word on the pages and
experience yeah yeah there's something
meditative about it though like reading
because it's so simple the act of just
plain white you know when you open a
book it's like code you know if you to
the uninitiated like you know it's you
have to but in a sense like that the
fact that it's so simple that there
aren't pictures you know it doesn't if
there were pictures I think in in books
as a standard it would
to break you out of it you know comics a
very different media to reading yeah and
I don't necessarily do super well with
those like I feel like I've read a lot
of good comics really really good ones
but I'm not so much about the art as me
as a person I'm more about the words on
the page and the art is that as a
decoration I think that yeah like like
sometimes yeah anyway Harry Potter I'm
taking over the show and what this
reason I'm still talking about how
culture is because I've been reading
this fanfic and I'm a little bit guilty
talking about that oh well yeah I feel a
little bit I don't know like dirty
reading a fanfic and I'm not sure I
should be getting as much joy out of it
as I am
in a sense like in I guess what we have
now is that we have a very large
community of people around how pots and
we've always had like Pottermore and
like the web sites and there's a huge
amount of fanfic out there and obviously
when you get something that's a big deal
like Star Wars there's a whole extended
universe full of of books which I kind
of thinker in their little ways a little
bit like fanfic you know yeah they are I
don't mean it so I think if the Star
Wars is an interesting one because
that's such a big corporate universe
because the parallel for me is what have
a forty thousand yeah
which has huge number of books published
but then they do directly feed into the
law so they're less fan fiction II where
so again my Harry Potter I suppose is
that standalone the other thing I've got
for example is World of Warcraft you
know I played that for about ten years
there was a very very big part of my
life when I was at university I was kind
of a bit reclusive and ended up playing
a lot of games with with people that I
would team with but also met a lot of
people online it was kind of a bit of an
escape but also I really took a lot of
joy out of it and I'm therefore I'm very
invested in that at first and so reading
the sort of books around that have been
they're not good books but because it's
something dear to me it's improved for
me yeah but you say they're not good if
you think they're not written well yeah
I don't think they would be like
particularly
they're written okay Jeremy narrow their
competence I think it's like you know
it's like okay it's not going to be game
breaking it's not gonna be something
that you need to finish at the earlier
like wow that was great you're like that
was that was its like potatoes and peas
and and I like a cheap hamburger it's
like edible you know and I think a lot
of content is like that you know it's
just kind of it doesn't have to be great
but it just has to be good enough for
you so now I've been reading this this
fanfic called Harry Potter and the
methods of rationality okay I have heard
about this one which is written by this
guy I can't remember his name I think
it's like al-azhar yet danowsky he
sounds like a Dark Wizard is that his
room
oh is in like it's an it's a pseudonym
no I think it is his real name and he's
basically a guy who would when he was a
teenager have been flagged up as a slash
I am very smart right like there's a
subreddit of people who love to who were
not smart necessary but think they are
and they lord over other people it's a
dangerous thing to have right it's a
very specific character type you're not
fast so I like to humble and a lot of
scientists are very humble or because
some of the most experts artists in
their field think they are still kind of
it's not an impostor syndrome
necessarily but but think they still
have interesting things to learn yes
it's the confidence curve isn't it with
the level of knowledge
yeah and all did you get the more you
realize how little you learn up and a
little II know up until the point and I
when you renewable prize-winning
scientists presumably you start getting
a little bit more confident you know
yeah at least the Nobel Prize gives you
a big ego boost yeah to the point where
you maybe start feeling a bit cocky that
you're but that's a dangerous path to
walk down anyway this guy wrote this
obviously again a big Harry Potter fan
but also a philosopher of someone who's
well-read has obviously taken
Harry Potter and sort of made it almost
like a parallel universe where people
don't do stupid things okay now I think
there's a it's
very easy to forgive stupidity in TV and
and film and stories and books in
general like when a character does
something stupid and everyone saw what
stupid idiot everyone else says well
there wouldn't be a book if he wasn't
stupid yeah yeah and that's such a lazy
horrible half assed excuse because that
is not how people act what the know
people do act a logically like they're
not perfectly logical the entire time
when people do stupid stuff at a time
and you're like why did you do that like
that was stupid but I think that
sometimes it's frustrating when you've
got a character who's whose I don't know
like for example with red rising I mean
I like red rising
I like the series I've read up to iron
gold so I think that's like the fourth
one and I think they're great so red
rose if you don't know it's about this
sort of universe about 200 years in the
future where kind of the like a
Romanesque caste based system of goulds
runs that gap runs that they're known as
or service system and they have this
solar Empire where they kind of lord
over it what and it look in the lower
castes
you know Silver's who were kind of like
the accountants or whatever and then
you've got like greens who were the
engineers or blue sue like I don't know
he goes down side the Browns were the
cleaners I don't know it's written by a
guy who's he's quite good and it's quite
it's quite good I think it's okay it's
good yeah it's not great but it's good
and I found it very difficult to get on
with the main character who is at the
same time a genius but can't see like an
incredibly obvious juggernaut heading
his way like Joe Pino I suppose that is
the infallibility of people when you
have to let go sometimes but sometimes I
it was almost too much to bear yeah it
was it felt irrational people would make
these decisions that were too irrational
and you couldn't put yourself in their
heads anymore that's the classic problem
like horror movies isn't it they
introduced you go cabin in the woods
in front of it like you know we should
split up all these things do you watch
community yeah for sure looking it says
the episode where they all take tests to
tell horror stories and it sounds like
Albert's version where they just stand
in the center of the room facing
opposite directions
listening to the radio and it's all
perfectly rational and so it's
incredibly okay perhaps what I'm trying
to ask it is it incredibly boring like
how where does the conflict come from in
the story if people act entirely
rationally well that's the thing if you
have very smart people trying to
outsmart each other then it's a it's a
joy to watch like I think when okay so
JK Rowling's suited in his Robert
Galbraith yeah and she's written a
series of these books called the corner
and strike books right they've actually
been made into TV shows which I haven't
seen but this this I think this the
Cuckoo's calling and a couple of other
ones and I think there's a fourth one
she said she was gonna write ten more
which is madness but I think they're
pretty good so they're about they're
kind of a detective story about this
ex-soldier called
corner and strife strike who lost his
leg in Afghanistan is now a grumpy
private detective boozing his way around
London with a hot secretary who is JK
Rowling basically she's inserted herself
into that full MarySue you know it's
like and she's like oh you know she
wants to be in kind of I get it like she
is she starts off as kind of a bit like
a ten because that's what JK Rowling was
she was a temp she worked she knows
she's writing kind of about what she
knows I think it's partly to take a
little bit of a division why Harry
Potter is so joyous when you look at
certain other places like physical Japan
a lot of anime a lot of manga a lot of
stories are set in school schools is
this thing we all go through we all have
a big association because you know and
yet in our media it feels very small
part of what we can shoot yeah let's
talk about like for example my hero
academia is a really really good
animator moment it's like recognized
well nice is one other I recommend it I
really have enjoyed going through it and
the schools are setting makes it
powerful I think Hogwarts is the iconic
thing about how bored that's what people
will remember that
remember the house system because I it
was it was familiar to me you know our
house a school had four houses yes it
was quite an old building you know it
had some teachers who were [ __ ] and
homework and detention and all the stuff
that you find familiar and so it's very
easy to get into that world I think it's
easier to build books as less baggage
you know you can already fill in a lot
the gaps in your mind but that makes it
more rich I think that that build-up
helps to like when you have a lot of
build-up to a story and the more you
enrich it the more it pays off I mean
when you've got a movie you've only got
two hours and I feel like the Harry
Potter movies were weakened because you
didn't have the time to build up to
those get to know those characters well
enough like you do in a book in the same
way that Game of Thrones you know I'd
really like Game of Thrones Game of
Thrones I see oh I really like Game of
Thrones I've read Game of Thrones back
in the day when it sort of first again
like I think I got into a feast for
crows that was the one I was bought by
my friend and then I obviously followed
them since then but my interest again
was wicked like when Game of Thrones the
TV show started coming out I initially
was a little bit I've already read this
already seen it but as it was it was
actually done very very well the early
series of Game of Thrones yeah great
but then my interest over time has waned
to the point where now I'm like I'm
watching them but now I'm moving I'm not
getting exactly now we're into
fanfiction again so coming back to your
question I will answer it a bit of a
roundabout way on the screen editing
Simon I feel like the UK this book does
treat Voldemort and Harry as if they
aren't just stupid
the thing is Harry Potter comes into the
Wizarding World but forgets about the
the muggle world incidentally where he
spent 11 years there
he should know stuff he should have some
contact with that thing I know that it's
trying to teleport you into a parallel
dimension where they have their own
concerns and the muggle world is
separate I feel like they do in to
interconnect with the muggle world
sometimes and it's done in a way that
isn't rational like Voldemort isn't
smart he doesn't behave
cunningly and cleverly you know he's not
he got he almost took over the world as
this Dark Wizard but yet now he acts
like an idiot doing things like an
incredibly over elaborate plot and I
understand it because JK Rowling is now
writing detective novels she wrote the
Harry Potter stories like they were
detective novels so she put in all the
clues and you solved the mystery oh it
turned out it was the rats all along
that was that the wizard the evil wizard
you know he was transferred to a rat she
laid all the the traps she said okay
this Wizards can turn into animals and
you have an animal where he's there from
the star and she plotted it out and
they're good like as that they have
oh wow these revenue revolutionary
moments but you're like okay that makes
sense now I'm not saying the whole books
are bad they're not they're very good I
really liked them they were the thing
that she worked to train for the Robert
Galbraith novels I know I think they're
written in they're written well you know
that she was an English teacher she
understood how to construct a story what
were the parts needed to assemble it the
Lego bricks to make a story they've been
made it made sense she wrote them in one
go over the course of the year they're
not perfect but what I'm saying is that
I'm not saying that you could improve
them either necessarily like if you
rewrote them all but this is kind of
what these the methods of rationality is
partly doing in a sense it's like
looking at what would happen if this
didn't happen you know would Harry
really have been sorted into Gryffindor
would Hermione have gone to Gryffindor
no no she should have been in ravenclaw
yeah so it kind of opens up the
possibility of people being in different
houses like what that would have meant
for them what the house is really meant
and also some really interesting things
about Harry Potter that you kind of
don't necessarily see on the first time
run through you when you realize in
Harry Potter that why why a Hogwarts
allow and Slytherin to still go
you know when it's basically the dark
wizards come out of there it's
completely corrupt against Mark Bloods
you know like why are they still
allowing
Professor Snape to be such a bully to
these kids you know like literally
almost child abuse level bullying like
why are they allowing that to happen
like there's certain things like an
Azkaban as well like it's basically a
torture chamber where they torture
Wizards to death and I understand that
some of the wisdom world is still
sitting
Middle Ages but no one addresses that in
the story you know and at the end of
Harry Potter all the bad ones go to
Azkaban and they get tortured to death
and it's like what what are we living in
you know hermione is trying to do you
know the save the house sales but house
elves are magical creatures that were
designed to get pleasure from helping
out and you want them to not help out
you wanna torture the house elves it's
all a lot of it it's like backwards and
not really rationally thought through
this is ruining Harry Potter to me in
retrospect I don't think ok I don't
think the point of reading these things
is to ruin Harry murder but it's to
provide an alternative headcanon that
enhances that law and I've really
enjoyed reading this this this thing
it's got problems it's a bit wordy
there's certainly problems with it and
certainly like sometimes you step back
and you roll your eyes and you're like
how could an 11 year old boy know this
yeah but it does fill in those gaps like
later on you realize okay why is he so
smart what has happened like what are
these things and in some ways it
provides alternative plots for Harry
Potter they're making more sense and so
it's kind of like oh yeah maybe that's
why this happened or maybe it would have
been better if this character was more
like this character
so overall I think you can look read it
all for free it's all yes HP mor calm if
I feel guilty talking about I also
wanted to like kind of defend myself
yeah this is your platform but this is
why I've been reading over the last sort
of three months really I mean I've been
reading other books as well I think it's
like sometimes you read a book and it'll
be it'll be a struggle to get through so
I talked about this book that I read off
Bill Gates's list of like books that you
should read and 107 Eve's and it's I've
heard about it's about a story about
basically the moon suddenly just
explodes one day and the impact that
would have on earth would basically mean
doomsday it would it would be the end of
life on Earth anyway the point is that
Earth has ten years or whatever to get
everyone into space or at least create
some sort of space place it's Colin
and so it's talking about that the first
half of the book is there and it's
actually very very good the second half
of the book is a story 5,000 years later
so the descendants of that colony yeah
and obviously the point the reason that
reason the book is called seven Eve's
not really a spoiler is that there are
seven Eve's side women only seven women
make it at all effectively but they've
got plenty sperm they got like a whole
you know sperm is like pretty let's go
play Oh Chris people I don't know why
they didn't have a library of X you know
but otherwise there would be a book
apparently sevens enough anyway the
point is that it looks at the sort of
descendants of of there those seven
Eve's
and and I actually really struggled to
get through that last half a book and
that kind of was the last of that was a
bit of a dent in like what I was able to
do so that those have been your recent
reads then briefly because this is this
video is now called the Ridley talked
about Harry Potter for 20 minutes ranks
what I've been what do you think are
your saw top five it doesn't have to be
five but your the books that you think
of influence do the most well have you
taken the most enjoyment out oh I don't
know
I I'm a firm proponent of trying
everything out like it might not be for
you but you've got to understand got
I've got to see you've got read
everything to see why it might be for
someone else so you know I recommend you
read I read Twilight I didn't like it it
wasn't for me but I understand it better
now and I feel like it was an
interesting study for me to read and I
read I read also stuff I read comic so I
watch anime you know I I don't watch
anime a lot but I watched the things
that are considered the good ones like
one punch man
yeah I'd haven't really read the manga
for it but I I wonder if I should in a
sense because in the same way that the
movies are not as good as the books you
know if you like here maybe you should
go back and
and read it you do seem to approach
content in a way without prejudice which
is quite refreshing you know you are not
because you know anime has a certain
reputation reading fanfiction has a
certain reputation
yeah that you feel that you're here to
defend but you don't you seem to consume
the content irrespective of how the rest
of society views it I'm definitely aware
that you know someone like period or
sips who I threw the trifles podcast
with are very much more discerning and
concerned about the the things they've
read and they're very much like this
isn't for me listen I know this isn't
gonna be for me
yeah and so I'm not even gonna try it
and I think that's a very naive take on
it cuz I think you can get a lot of joy
out of things I think Harry Potter is
gonna example that you know when I was
reading it I recommended my mum and dad
read it and they were initially very
hesitant but then they really did enjoy
the books as well and I think just
because they're called kids books or you
know that that stigma attached to
something can be a kind of a like it can
inhibit your joy you shouldn't you
shouldn't like like Star Wars it's a
kids movie if you like Star Wars you
like a kid's thing you do yeah they are
kids movies so that gif of Patrick
Willis I'm a huge huge fan of stars I
always have been you know and so like
like like you know so many things like
red rising it's a young adult book you
know it's but you don't have to have
that all the time like if you you have
to read adult books you have to read
horror and like I read neo nomicon which
is a comic Alan Moore's horrible comic I
was talking about reading I read on the
plane and its got like tentacle rape
from a Cthulhu monster in like full
graphic detail and I was like oh god I
was like reading on the plane I think
you skip the next pages even worse of
what everyone around me do you think I
was reading some like porn on there
came out of nowhere and I I knew that it
was like a furniture readers type thing
and I do like things that are like that
like Game of Thrones the books are if
definitely before mature readers like
there's some horrible stuff that happens
but that doesn't mean that's the only
thing you have to read just got you're
an adult it doesn't mean you've only
read adult books just suitable for kids
doesn't mean it's only readable by kids
that seems to be something of a societal
movement like the rise of someone like
John Green for example his books being
massively popular despite the fact that
they are really aimed at teenagers yeah
loads are you have you read anything
yeah I've got it Turtles all the way
down yes I really liked I really right
yeah I think it's great yeah I read
there I really enjoyed it and I mean I
read the Goldfinch as well which was
more of a conventional book very thick
and I iced lobbed my way to its it's but
it's kind of a book that turns and
changes except more conviction it's very
very slow and I will say that I was glad
it was over I didn't I wouldn't
recommend people read it but it's
certainly like there's it Donna Tartt I
think wrote it it's like it's quite a
famous write work the Goldfinch yeah
recently is also at the alchemist which
is a Paulo quelle heure whatever it's
like and something that the kids are
told to read in school often at least I
think in America and it's like a
philosophical thing about discovering
yourself it's a bit I think it felt a
little bit like a blunt force there's no
subtlety to it yeah
the metaphors were a bit heavy-handed
but I think I did enjoy it nonetheless I
read I read Siddhartha by Hermann Hesse
which is again like a pretty good book
and has sort of messages about being a
good person and like just trying to live
a like a simple ascetic life of it's
nice to put things in perspective I mean
and I think your technique of reading
basically incredibly widely is that it's
providing different perspectives on the
same subject it's really nice to just
get like a shotgun effect of reading
everything from from
like pulpy crap like you know John
Grisham II crap or bad I really like the
original Sherlock Holmes I read all of
those when I was like walking so I had
audiobooks I'd like go for an hour walk
and read this - a short poems that was
something I did perhaps or 10 years ago
and I really enjoyed doing that but also
like just books that are highly
recommended from like you know justjust
anything like a lot of going back and
reading stuff that I was given as
assignments in school I hate it and some
I still hate yeah like if mice and men I
still think everybody at my school
painted it but like the only person
who's ever read it in English class has
actually enjoyed it okay well I didn't
like that and I didn't like a lot of
stuff like scarlet letters just it's
very American but you just just didn't
like your approach here the message to
take home I think from this is read read
body mind I didn't like it yeah I think
that I want to reform mmm and now do you
do mostly do physical books do you do
audiobook I do mall ready about some
physical books but it's a dangerous game
with audiobooks because you can this
it's it's always the danger I've had to
wrestle hard with putting books down
because you know when you buy a book you
want to get your money's worth you want
to get through it you wanna finish it
you wanna you wanna see it's at the end
and I think when you're halfway through
something it's easy to say I'm not
really enjoying this but I don't want to
read it and that is a real horrible
place to be if you're not enjoying a
book to the point at which you start you
have to be very conscious that you're
not enjoying it and either you're going
to push on or you're gonna abandon it
and I think don't be scared to abandon
stuff if you're like its pissing you off
it's like I'm not interested in reading
it this is not sparking joy or whatever
it's not making me break my habits to
read like I remember the other book that
really was very good for the first one
was a name of the wind by I really
enjoyed that when I read it like 10
years ago
and the second one was terrible and I
couldn't get through it you know and so
I gave up and I wasn't
and actually did the same thing with
malazan but could the fallen by Erickson
I read a lot of his stuff and then I got
to liked all the hounds and I got
halfway through and I just like I can't
deal with this I'm just not interested
and so I gave up on that as well and
just didn't come back and wasn't wasn't
I think I don't feel bad for not
finishing it but I do feel a little bit
bad but if I had if I had pushed through
you would have missed out on the
opportunity read something else yeah I
think so
we I need to get you off to recording so
that is a lot of words but what I'd like
to do is at the end of all these book
kind of videos where I'm interviewing
someone I do there's ten questions from
I don't know if you've ever seen inside
the Actor's Studio
oh yeah yeah so I just sort of get a
sense of who is the room though it's
windy what is your favorite word flange
it's like a kind of it's a good because
it's like rude but also it's like a
mechanical thing it's like a mechanical
part I like machines and cogs and
conveyor belts and I feel like you need
a flange for somewhere in there so it
makes it work I can imagine like an old
like a work with saying past me possibly
the number four flange and then like the
I don't know anyway okay what is your
least favorite word I think it would be
what was it I went into my head
immediately was cancer I really that I
don't like I don't like that word I
don't think anyone does it's strangely
negative but also I think that when we
did I did when we did this interview
before we interviewed one of my friends
that he's favorite word was cancer but
his least favorite word was also cancer
ah I've read it as written here what
turns you on creatively spiritually or
emotionally it's got to be anything that
you you have to let anything that makes
you wake up in the morning and jump out
bed right you have to try and find those
things in your life right you have to
you have to want to beat sight for the
day like so I wake up and I'm like I'm
excited for this thing today when you go
down and you like you do it you know
it's like it's
a particular thing though the sparks
that I knew at the moment no no it's
anything that is I don't know this
there's a lot of things that that I get
a joy from and it changes on a day to
day whether it's the book I'm reading
the series I'm doing like the thing I'm
working on that I don't know anything
the piece of are I made yesterday or
whatever or you know what it's you have
to find it's different every day
hmm what's the opposite what turns you
off I don't know what turns me off is is
drama
honestly like like people like like
people who've been upset for some reason
and I can't put my finger on how to
solve those problems like you know
that's what that's what keeps me up at
night is like or makes my heart pound in
my chest is when someone says to me like
I've had this falling out with this
person I didn't what to do about it and
like cuz I'm I hate being not being able
to help I guess I'm a control freak in
their sense where I can't it's tough to
just say that sounds bad man somedays
you like think okay I'll just pack it
all in I'm just I'm not gonna do
anything anymore you know that could
that could really crush your spirits
just some negativity from someone I
think overall like that's the thing we
experience a lot of in our businesses a
lot of drama a lot of trolling I'm not
saying that the negativity is this thing
that really affects me I think it
affects other people heavily the more
heavily that affects me I have a
background of being a troll on the
internet so I'm a bit more immune to it
I always assume that anyone who's
trolling me on the Internet is either an
idiot or a child because in my
experience they are one of the two but
you can it never entirely makes you you
know yeah I think some people were very
much more sensitive to it and another
sorry I'm sorry a bit of a diversion on
that right let's let's let's keep these
two short answers you can get you off
yes boss what is your favorite curse
word
I think it's like shite right I don't
know it's like kind of is not that rude
especially if you say in like a Scottish
accent like yo mean shite I just like it
it's quite cute you know what sound or
noise do you love I think I think fart
sounds just just various for like really
[ __ ]
Foley BBC like all of you know like a
record they've got like you know they've
got like background sounds you know like
old school fart sounds just like like
okay what sound or noise do you hate oh
it's obviously this says I don't like
the sound of other people eating like
all drinking loudly with their mouths
open it's the thing that we get on
Twitch complaints about a lot because
you know some stream was like and but
some people do it way more irritatingly
than others and you sit there watching
them like good girl good girl and
everyone of them you're like just slowly
getting more annoyed and the most
awkward thing about it is you can't tell
them because they can you drink less
quietly and they're like that [ __ ]
that's just a control freak
you know you there's no there's no way
out of that you can't let them know hmm
you just have to put up with it what
profession other than your own would you
like to attempt oh man I'd like to be an
explorer you know like I wish I could
have like in an old life being like put
on one of those colonial hats and just
go on and like trekked up a mountain or
across Antarctica or something you know
being part of like an exploratory thing
oh yeah or being like on a boat like
running a boat going off and like
picking up weird animals and bringing
them back Joe of Doral person Charles
Darwin yeah just like grabbing all the
turtles and what would you not like to
attempt yeah probably not those things I
just said actually
even though our life wouldn't it same
ancestor vote okay
little final question if Heaven exists
what would you like to hear God's say it
when you arrive at the pearly gates I
would like him to say you're right
heaven doesn't exist by and then just
like nothing just like you know he's
like a gate keeper to nothing or he's
like he may be he tells people they were
wrong and he's like ha you thought there
was heaven unlucky kind of thing like
that would be good yeah like I just I
just want him to like well maybe he
tells people I don't know
morality changes right I'm sure a bunch
of people have gone to or assume heaven
i it's bollocks
probably heaven is right thank you very
much Luis as soon as you start trying to
think about it it just instantly pokes
holes in it oh yeah oh yeah like you
can't think about that without poking
holes in it where can people find you on
the internet I'm on various things
yogscast lewis yeah I'll put all the
titles of your channels have just flown
up on the screen now because there's too
many to name
yeah I do podcast I do I play see if I
play minecraft and you know it's it's
it's great I enjoy I enjoy my day-to-day
and yeah we're doing we do a charity
thing every Christmas it's really good
so yes you can check it out you don't
have to do what you want
thank you very much and there'll be
links to all the books that was talked
about in the description bye